翻訳: Abram Leon
校正: Masako Kigami
本日は古神道の本質について
お伝えしたいと思っております
特に「包み込む」という考え方についてです
まず自己紹介をさせていただきます
よく 私 自己紹介をいたしますと
「ご職業は何ですか？」と聞かれます
名刺をお渡しても
だいたい無言で「シーン」と
(笑）
ひどい方はそのまま後ろに
スーッと下がっていかれます
(笑）
「あ どこか行かれましたね」って話です
それで 名刺を見ていただきますと
古武道、古神道、陰陽道 と言った形で
書かれてはいるんですけど
言葉としては読みますが
やっぱり意味が分からないと
それで私は一言「あの 神主です」と
あるいは「祭司です」とお伝えすると
皆さん「あ～」
言葉じゃないですね
一言いただきます
(笑）
はい
この瞬間がとても面白い
私は自己紹介が趣味と言いますか
はい 楽しんでおります
この世界に入りましたら
もうはや30年超えておりまして
もともと ちょっと辿りますと
身近に古神道、陰陽道
あと古武道というものがあった
というのがまずきっかけです
最初はま小ちゃいころからやっておりますので
覚えるだけですよね
意味が分からないままどんどん
どんどん覚えていくんですけど
最初は楽しいということもあって
ずっと夢中にやっておりました
大体 学校に入る頃にですね
どうも周りと違うということに気づきはじめます
「あれ？なんでこれが通じないの？」とか
「あれはこうした方がいいんじゃないの」と言ったら
「いや それは・・・」と
例えば 刀
刀が家にあるとは思いませんが
（笑）
まず剣道の竹刀の持ち方と
刀の持ち方まったく違います
ですから 剣道でこう持つ
刀との持ち方からすると
皆さんから「それは違う」と言われますね
ですから そういった細かいところは
だんだん摩擦になっていきまして
大体 時間が経つにつれて
ちょっと 少数派です かなり
（笑）
はい
ですから 周りから色々とあるので
だんだん疲れてきまして
それでこの道を捨ててしまうという
結果に至りました
それで 決定的だったのは
会社就職ですよね
就職することでこの道を
完全に捨ててしまいました
就職したのはIT産業です
開発という仕事にしておりまして
そこの世界は 勝つか負けるか
出世するかどうかの世界でしたので
どんどん どんどんと
出世を目指していきます
そうすると 普段から気力
体力を培っておりましたから
パワーで勝てるんですよ
それで やっているうちにもう
このままいったら確実に
トップだなと思っている時に
過労で体を壊しまして
全く動けなくなりました
その時に初めてこの道に
戻るきっかけになりました
当初 当然 先程お伝えした通り
誰も知りませんから
「なんで自分の体力が
こんなに高かったんだろう？」
「気力も高かったんだろう？」
あと 能力ですよね
日々研鑽していましたから
大体のこと
ちょっと考えれば分かると言いますか
色々裏技があります
そういったとこを使っておりましたので
「そういったのはなんでだろう」という所に
疑問を持ちはじめまして
まず 当然周りに聞けませんから
一つ一つ思い返しては
何をしたかということを
ずっと検証してきました
そうすると一つ結論が出まして
これはどうも そもそも古神道という
この日本に古来からあるものが
そういった本質を持っていたってことに
気付いた瞬間なんです
気付いてから 分かったことは
もともと古神道って古い時間
歴史を持っていますので
当然古いから趣味的に
やっているものと思うんですが
古いものこそ新しいというのは
実は古神道だったんです
そうすると 「あ なるほど」と
その瞬間から私も古神道と一緒に
生きている感覚になりまして
今に至っております
この古神道で一つお伝えしたいことが
まず先程お伝えした「包み込む」という考え方です
この「包み込む」をお伝えする前に
ちょっと ご質問をいたします
まず一言
「包み込む」という一言で 皆さん
どういう印象お持ちでしょうか？
大体こう 愛情があるとか
本当に暖かいって感覚があると思うんですね
次のご質問をいたします
「過ちを包み込む」という感覚はどうでしょう？
「妥協した」という感覚もあれば
「許した」って感覚は出てくると思います
なにか先程の暖かさは少し減って
なにか違うものが見えてきている
次 ライバルとかの「宿敵」
「宿敵を包み込む」というと皆さん
かなり昔の話を思い返しながら
多分誰かの顔を思い出しながら
「包み込む」というのを考えているかと思います
つまり 先程の「包み込む」という一つの単語であれば
皆さん同じ意味を持っているんですが
言葉に 文章にした時に
それぞれ記憶 あるいは感情というものが
意味を変えています
ですから 実は 言葉を間違えているという
よく指摘するとかそういった
シーンが見受けられますが
実は意味が違うってことはないんです
それぞれに意味が持っているってことです
まず ここをご認識いただきたいというのは一つです
次に 言霊という話をさせていただきますと
日本語というのは 五十音ありますと
他の 当然言霊と言いますと
他の 西洋とか あるいは
他の文化にも当然あるんですが
五十音一つ一つに意味があるっていう言語は
実は日本語しかないですね
ですから 先は「包み込む」は「つ」と「つ」と「む」
これだけで三つの意味があるという解釈をします
ですから 先程「つつむ」を合わすと
少なくは四つの意味を
無意識で感じ取っているということです
こういったところを
まずご理解いただければ
すごく 日本語というものを
よく分かってくるかと思います
そうしますと 色々と意味が違う
最初は当然少し形も
今回お伝えするために
少し簡単にお伝えしているところもあります
そういった裏話をしますと
「じゃあ 何が一体 全体正しいんだ」とか
「間違えているんだ」とかの話になってくるんですけど
ここでちょっとお伝えしたいことは
まず 古神道の本質的なもう一つの考え方が
「有るは無い」「無いは有る」と言います
凄い究極的な矛盾なんですけど
実は この矛盾をどう解釈するかが
文化の特徴とその成熟だと私は感じています
つまり 陰陽 白黒つけたがる文化もあれば
「ま それはそれでありかな」と
思う文化もあると思うんですね
そういったところの解釈は
どうなっているかというところです
それともう一つは
白黒つけないというのも
すごく大事だと思っています
敢えてそのまま受け取るということです
これはそれぞれの有り様です
皆さんの有り様をまず受け取ってからどうするか
ひょっとすると解釈できない
理解できないというのは当然でして
そもそもそのまま受け取ってみては
いかがでしょうか？
まずは何もしない
相手がどう感じているか
つまり あなたが間違えている あなたが正、悪
正邪ですね
あるいはどう解釈
私が解釈するかは関係なく
まずその方の有り様をそのまま受け止めて
いただきたいなと思っています
当然
これは結構 白黒つける
あるいは妥協するって考える方もいらっしゃいます
それは少しおいといてください
まずは その方が何を言ったのか
これは文化にも当てはまります
あるいはその価値観
社会的なもの何でも構いませんが
「まずは受け止めてしまう」
というのも一つの答えかと思っています
当然受け止めには
体力も気力も必要です
だって頭の中で無意識に
これは正しいか 間違えているか
勝手に頭が動き始めますが
それを止めないといけませんので
考えを「ウッ」と
大体 「ウッ ウッ」ともがくと思います
ですがその先に
やはり楽しみ というのもまたありますし
相手を理解するというところで
また面白い感覚が芽生えてくるかと
思っています
ですからまずは何も解釈しない
白黒をつけない
そういったところをまず踏み込んでいただいて
むしろそれは楽しい感情として
受け止めていただければと思っております
ありがとうございました
（拍手）